[Musique]
lors de la COP15 sur la biodiversité à
Montréal le défi était immense réunir
196 délégations autour d'une vision
commune pour préserver la vie sur la
planète
sur fond de tension politique
[Applaudissements]
à travers le regard de ceux qui l'ont
vécu Anne la rigauderie et Paul élu
depuis plus d'une décennie collige les
meilleures connaissances scientifiques
sur la biodiversité
basilvanabre coprisez les négociations
depuis quatre ans Eddy Perez il
travaille alors pour le Réseau Action
Climat Canada il est là pour faire
entendre la voix de la société civile et
des groupes écologistes
un jour avant l'ouverture de la COP 15
le moral est bas l'état des lieux
actuellement en matière de négociations
c'est chaotique les négociations
officielles n'ont pas débuté mais les
délégués ont déjà commencé à débattre
cette fin de semaine 60 heures en trois
jours alors vous avez assisté auprès
négociation
comment ça s'est passé
gouvernements à ce moment il a été un
des auteurs principaux de plusieurs
rapports importants sur l'état de la
biodiversité mondiale c'était pas
inattendu mais c'est trois premières
journées c'était complètement déprimant
la COP15 c'est le dernier jalon de
quatre ans de travail c'est pour créer
ce texte un cadre mondial pour la
biodiversité qui doit guider les actions
des gouvernements pour la prochaine
décennie les dernières négociations qui
ont eu lieu au printemps un aérobie ont
été difficiles elles ont mené un texte
comportant 955 segments entre crochets
sur 27 pages ces termes entre crochets
sont ceux qui ne font pas consensus qui
sont encore à négocier les délégués ont
deux semaines pour s'entendre sur ce
texte chaque pays a ça à sa
compréhension sur les objectifs et la
problématique qu'on est venu résoudre et
il faut s'entendre en fait sur le même
vision qui doit s'incruster dans le cas
de mondial à la fin de la journée
[Musique]
ce sera la responsabilité de la Chine à
la présidence de la Coop de diriger ses
négociations
pour avoir un cadre qui mènera des
bénéfices concrets tous en tendent il
faut se doter de cible précise la
première version du cadre s'appuyait en
grande partie sur les recommandations
des scientifiques des chiffres ambitieux
protégez 30% des terres et des mers pour
2030 restaurer 20% des surfaces
terrestres et marines réduire de moitié
l'utilisation des engrais et pesticides
première version était vraiment
très bien
mais il s'est écoulé quatre rondes de
négociation depuis des crochets se sont
ajoutés
quel est l'espoir que ces chiffres-là
restent très difficile à dire donc
certains sont beaucoup plus contestés
que d'autres et surtout des questions
comme les pesticides on sait qu'il y a
beaucoup
d'intérêts financiers derrière et il est
vraiment à craindre qui est pas de
quantification peut-être même que les
pesticides seront pas nommés dans la
dans la cible sur sur la pollution de
les pesticides c'est un sujet qui fâche
c'est le début des négociations il y a
certaines nos chercheurs qui sont
coincés à l'extérieur parce qu'il y a
des manifestations on va aller voir si
on peut trouver quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
à Corée rédiger la première version du
cadre mondial il l'a vu évoluer mot par
mot et pendant cette COP15 il poursuit
la composidence des négociations sur le
document parce que la lumière absolument
c'est que je vois les gens en train de
bouger je vois les gens en train de se
parler et établir des structures pour
permettre du dialogue entre les chefs de
délégation
ici sont réunis les négociateurs des
délégations des différents pays mais
aussi les représentants d'ONG de la
société civile ce matin tous présentent
leurs attentes la pression est là il
faut y arriver on au ministre arrive
dans une dizaine de jours je pense que
aucune des délégations devait me mettre
devant leur ministre le texte dans
l'état actuel
qu'il fallait un peu changer d'attitude
les crochets commencèrent tomber donc là
je crois qu'il y a pour la première fois
j'ai senti qu'il y avait un peu voilà la
volonté de construire quelque chose
ensemble dans les négociations la
pression est forte pour s'entendre sur
la conservation de 30% des terres et des
mers pour 2030 mais des objections sont
soulevées donc on a fait ou et c'est
financé par qui
et l'autre grand débat et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec des terres qui sont
occupés par des peuples autochtones
on est vendredi soir et les négociateurs
ont à peine abordé les cibles les plus
importantes il ne reste plus que
quelques jours avant des ministres et
d'ici là il faut résoudre un maximum
d'enjeux nettoyer le texte pour ne
transmettre que les questions les plus
difficiles au ministre
nous sommes environ un ami parcours de
la plus importante et la plus impérieuse
Conférence des Nations Unies sur la
biodiversité depuis une génération
on commence une nouvelle semaine
beaucoup plus politique il y a l'arrivée
des ministres 130 ministres qui arrivent
avec leurs équipes leurs avocats avec un
mandat de leur pays à défendre quelque
chose donc ça change la dynamique si au
deuxième si au deuxième on va défendre
par là nous accompagnons Basile vanabre
vers la séance de négociation de cet
après-midi menée à huis clos on a ici un
groupe informel donc on a demandé à deux
pays de prendre le lead il y a peut-être
une demi douzaine de pays qui sont en
train de travailler sur le libellé de
quelques phrases sur une cible moi je
pense que aujourd'hui des groupes
restreints tentent de s'entendre sur la
question des pesticides beaucoup de pays
en bois de Bermont ne voyaient très mal
les mots utilisation de pesticides
réduire l'utilisation de pesticides donc
scientifiquement la quantité de
pesticides utilisées est un non-sens
c'est à dire que c'est le risque qui
sont associés avec les pesticides qui
est extrêmement importante et donc
en reformulant ce cible en termes de
risque de paye en voie de vraiment sont
beaucoup plus
ouverts à l'idée de d'avoir le mot
pesticides dans la cible s'il était
associé que avec le risque et pas
l'utilisation tous les pays sont là ils
sont par région
[Musique]
à partir d'aujourd'hui les ministres
prennent en main les négociations liées
aux ambitions politiques dont les
principales cibles chiffrées
[Musique]
les négociations politiques se
poursuivent à huit lots entre les
ministres
à 2h du matin hier Basile vanabre a
conclu la partie plus technique des
négociations sur le cadre mondial hier
c'était la dernière soirée comment ça
s'est terminée c'était assez difficile
je pense que d'un côté les les
négociateurs les délégations sont
fatigués donc il y a moins d'énergie
pour faire des consensus quand bien même
on n'avait pas beaucoup de de consensus
sont toujours ses crochets rester là les
uns après les autres
on est passé au travers de toute la de
toute la liste
on est à une journée de la fin prévue de
la COP15 en ce moment on arrive en coin
tournant ce qu'on appelle type de façon
candide le moment de panique comment
dire on fait un bilan
[Musique]
là c'est pour ça qu'il y a beaucoup de
monde parce que c'est vraiment un moment
important pour voilà pour un peu sentir
reprendre le bout de ce qui se passe
[Musique]
la première chose c'est peut-être de
dire que le ton reste malgré tout
constructif
[Musique]
général des scientifiques à ce stade-ci
à l'écoute des négociations qui sont ils
sont déçus par
la nature la teneur des négociations
donc il y a vraiment voilà ils ont
l'impression d'avoir un peu prêché dans
le désert malgré tout donc c'est sûr que
c'est difficile de pour eux de de pas
être découragé
la présidence chinoise annonce qu'avec
son équipe elle produira une proposition
de cadre mondial qui pourra faire
consensus elle sera soumise aux
commentaires des délégués demain à 8
heures
on a vu un texte une proportion de la
présidente chinoise
ça a pris tout le monde par surpris en
fait
le texte proposé est beaucoup plus
ambitieux qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
négociations politiques ont porté fruits
et la présidence fait le pari que les
pays accepteront ses ambitions quand
j'ai vu que il y avait quand même
énormément de pays qui à l'ouverture du
débat on dit on veut pas réouvrir ce
texte là il est bon c'est jamais arrivé
c'est un on n'a jamais vu ça dans une
coque
mais le consensus est fragile et la
rumeur court que la présidence veut
faire adopter les textes dès ce soir on
a un document qui est quand même solide
c'est vrai il y a quand même beaucoup
des éléments dont on avait parlé au
départ presque tous sur la restauration
le pourcentage est encore plus ambitieux
que ce qu'on avait dit vous rappeler au
début on est parlé de 20% donc pendant
cette 30%, c'est bien les herbes
protégés
la cible sur les pesticides qui est
toujours là donc
sur le nutriments perdus vers
l'environnement donc les engrais donc
c'est très ambitieux à cela s'ajoute une
entente de financement des pays riches
de 30 milliards de dollars vers les pays
du Sud si on fait tout ce qu'on a on
s'est engagé à faire c'est une
révolution c'est pas un changement la
marge c'est c'est un changement
extrêmement important notamment dans le
domaine de l'agriculture
[Musique]
des négociations entre ministres se sont
poursuivis toute la journée les délégués
attendent une dernière version des
textes avant d'amorcer la séance
des négociations de dernière minute
retable début de la plénière
ayez deux heures dix du matin et les
documents viennent finalement d'être mis
en ligne donc là on a donné une
vingtaine de minutes au délégué pour les
consulter et se faire une opinion dessus
[Musique]
et ici sur la clause 31 je sais pas
c'est pareil quand je vois les ministres
en train de se parler de circuler
la présidence s'apprête à faire adopter
les documents mais à satisfaite des
négociations des dernières heures et des
montants transférés vers les pays du Sud
la République du Congo refuse d'appuyer
le texte nous recommandons de mettre
sous crochet le projet actuel du cadre
mondial la biodiversité poste 2020
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a consensus mais pas unanimité nous
regrettons que cet espace soit un espace
où on fait ovation à la violence
contre notre texte que nous avions tous
adoptés
et ça l'histoire ne nous le pardonnera
jamais merci
c'est la fin d'un processus qui aura
duré quatre ans le texte a évolué nous
avons évolué nos points de vue évolués
au cours des quatre ans ce qui est
important c'est que ça soit le texte des
parties de la Convention et qui sont
mises en place ce texte est une promesse
un bout de papier sans contrainte légale
et pour qu'il devienne vraiment
historiques les pays devront tenir cette
promesse
[Musique]